- Do you ever wish that you had a tail?
You could swing your way to school,
bake pies more efficiently,
and carry an umbrella while
keeping your hands free.
The funny thing is, you
did have a tail once,
before you were born.
Back then, you were an embryo.
An embryo is an organism that
is in the earliest stages
of development before
it is born or hatched.
Early on in the growth of a human embryo,
the embryo has a tail-like structure.
As time goes on, the embryo grows,
and eventually the cells that
made up that tail structure
shift and form the tailbone,
which makes up the bottom of the spine.
By the time the embryo is eight weeks old,
the tail is not visible at all.
Humans are not the only species
to have tails as embryos.
We share this trait
with the embryos of
many other vertebrates,
which are animals with a backbone,
such as monkeys, mice,
turtles, and chickens.
Scientists call features
such as embryo tails
homologous features.
Structurally similar
anatomical features that
two species share that
indicate that the species
share a common ancestor.
Identifying homologous
features can help scientists
figure out how different species
are related to each other
and how they evolved.
Studying embryos is a
helpful way for scientists
to find similarities between species.
Similarities that might not be visible
once the animals are born and grow up.
In general, embryos of
related species have
more obvious homologous features
at earlier stages of development,
before the embryos anatomy
becomes highly specialized.
During the stages of
an embryos development,
the embryo goes through a
lot of physical changes.
The embryo of an elephant
starts out weighing
less than a gram and it eventually grows
to its birth weight of
about 100 kilograms.
Let's take a closer look
at the kinds of changes
the elephant embryo goes
through as it develops.
As an embryo grows, its
physical structures change.
Some structures become visible,
and others disappear.
For example, towards the
beginning of development,
an elephant embryo has structures called
pharyngeal arches, or
gill arches, on its neck.
As the embryo grows, the
pharyngeal arches change structure
and help form the ears
and jaws of the elephant.
And it turns out, all vertebrate embryos
have pharyngeal arches
early in their development.
In fish, these arches
develop into gill structures.
In humans and other mammals,
these arches develop into
ear and jaw structures, just
like they did in the elephant.
Pharyngeal arches are homologous features,
even though we can only
see this homologous feature
early on in embryo development.
Pharyngeal arches provide
evidence to scientists
that all vertebrates
share a common ancestor.
More distantly related
species tend to share
fewer homologous features
during both embryo development
and after birth.
More closely related
species tend to share more
homologous features during
both embryo development
and after birth.
So even though you don't have
a tail, as far as I know,
studying homologous features in embryos,
shows scientists that
humans are related to
many tail-using creatures
because of evolution.